we have to
maybe convince ourselves that this is
what we want to be doing this is fun for
us this is enjoyable hi there steve
kaufman here today i want to talk about
how to stay motivated when you're
learning a language remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
if you follow these podcasts on spotify
or apple podcasts or elsewhere please
leave a review
um so motivation it comes up all the
time we all know
that to be successful in anything it
helps to be genuinely motivated
and we also know that we are more
motivated at sometimes than at other
times
and so even in learning a language we
can be very moted motivated initially
for whatever reason and then we go
through periods where we're not
motivated so how do we stay motivated
well
first of all let's say that we can't be
equally motivated all the time so at
times your motivation will flag
however
i think the first thing about motivation
is to have a clear goal why are you
learning this language all right is it
because you want to communicate with
your in-laws in the old country
is it because you need it for a job is
it because you're interested in some
aspect of the culture or you have a
friend
or you want to travel you know make sure
you have some clear goal maybe you just
want to learn the language so you can
show off in front of others
perfectly legitimate
maybe you want to learn a language
because it's an improvement activity and
we all know that
you know as human beings if we can then
learn if we can learn if we can improve
ourselves it gives us a sense of
satisfaction it gets the i don't know
endorphins adrenaline or something
working in the brain we like that the
brain likes that the sense of of a task
the sense of acquiring knowledge
there's a great sense of achievement and
satisfaction
uh which which comes from that and those
are all legitimate reasons goals for
learning a language and i could probably
i'm sure
people out there have other goals that
are also legitimate any goal that
motivates you
to learn is is is important to have
so i think a big part of motivation is
the goal and when your motivation flags
you've got to remind yourself of why
you're doing it remind yourself of why
this is important to you to learn this
language and of course if it's no longer
important then maybe you should stop for
a while until you get that itch again
you know i want to learn this language
so
a big part of motivation is is the goal
the why
another big part of motivation is the
process itself
and i often say
you know the process is the reward if
you can enjoy the process of learning a
language
then you're not you're less concerned
about how quickly you're improving
because you're enjoying
hearing the sounds of the language
discovering new words new ways of saying
things
you're enjoying the fact that you
understand things now that you didn't
understand three or six months earlier
you're not frustrated by the fact
that you don't understand everything
so the the whole the process itself
uh
gives you a sense of achievement a sense
of enjoyment
so therefore you have to look for ways
to make that process enjoyable i've
talked about mixing in repetition which
is easier you know a lot of the content
and you're focusing in on some aspects
some structures in the language or some
ways in which words change in the
language some aspects of grammar in the
language so that those
listening to repetitious material can be
enjoyable but at the same time you want
to find enjoyable content
things of interest to you so that again
the process becomes enjoyable
you know and just as an aside
on twitter i sometimes comment on
different tweets that come my way and
some person had tweeted that
you know he's 16 and jobs any job he's
had is boring and he only gets a few
weeks off and he's got that's all he's
got to look forward to in his life
and i said well you know with an
attitude like that you're probably
better to quit the job if you think the
job is genuinely pointless find another
job
uh because even in work if you can find
a way to enjoy the process you will be
more successful
uh and of course that brought an
avalanche of
twitter comments from people who were i
don't know
communists or whatever they were jobs
are all bad
the boss gets all the money we make
useless stuff that only goes to the rich
and all this other stuff
well and nobody enjoys their work and
you obviously were in a position of
power you old white man boomer or
whatever
i don't believe that when i go to a
restaurant i have the impression that
the server enjoys serving me
i have worked in factories i worked okay
i wasn't a permanent laborer there but i
have worked together with people in
factories for weeks on end i've also
been part of the management team and a
majority of people actually enjoy what
they do and those who do enjoy what they
do they do better
uh
because it's not just eight hours of
drudgery not to mention the fact that
you know it's a social environment where
they're together with their buddies and
it's an important part of their life
as we go through life no matter what our
activity is
you know we have some some ability to
control how we feel about that activity
we can decide that we're going to enjoy
that activity or not enjoy that activity
and it's not obvious that uh you know a
very wealthy person who's got nothing
but the best of everything to eat and
the biggest home is enjoying his life
more than someone who has a simpler life
but has lots of interest lots of friends
and family and relationships and stuff
so it's up to up to us and so that's
sorry for the digression but i think the
same is true
in our language learning
we have to
maybe convince ourselves that this is
what we want to be doing this is fun for
us this is enjoyable
so if we have these goals
and at the same time
we enjoy the process we we find things
that are enjoyable to do or we persuade
ourselves that this is worthwhile doing
this is what i want to be doing now so
that the process is enjoyable all of
these things are motivating
if we are frustrated by the difficulties
frustrated by our obvious
uh you know
problems in the language
which are part and parcel of learning it
because if we knew the language and made
no mistakes and understood everything
then we wouldn't need to learn it so
because we're learning it we are in fact
encountering these difficulties but we
can find a way to enjoy these
difficulties if we set our minds to it
so
those are sort of my main thoughts on on
motivation another thing that comes up
from time to time is
if you've been studying the same bit of
content and you kind of think you should
be doing this content because it's the
next level of difficulty but you're not
really interested in the content find
something else because there's a
tremendous
difference if we're interested like
let's say that it's something in the
language you're learning and it relates
to your job or relates to a sport that
you're interested in and skiing or
something and all of a sudden it's
interesting i mean that level of focus
that we can achieve when we have content
that's genuinely interesting you know is
is so much stronger that pull the
resonance is so much stronger than where
if we're studying something that we feel
we should study and we're kind of
pushing ourselves and forcing ourselves
so
make sure in order to maintain motiva
motivation that you work with content
that has some value to you either
because and i find myself very motivated
to listen to my mini stories over and
over again but at the same time
find things that are interesting so that
all of a sudden from being somewhat
passive and i should really do this you
all of a sudden wow i'm interested in
this and you'll see that you won't even
notice that you're learning the language
you won't even notice that the language
is washing over your brain because
you're pursuing something there that's
of interest to you and that helps with
motivation okay thank you for listening
bye for now